c'est quoi votre truc d'hommes du mois
[Rires]
ouais je suis chez nomura
c'est vrai alors je vous faire une
petite interview que tu d'accord avant
d'accueillir camille combal et bien sûr
de faire le défi avec denis bredin
il faut que je me transforme en passe
vous transforme en cas d'accord allez
juste que je prenne une ou quoi une
place de quotas voilà une passe de
voilages peut être de la côte et moi
donc attention vous dit vous êtes près
de ses mots avant de commencer cette
interview je voulais vous dire que
c'était très content de vous recevoir
dans l'émission merci d'où sort demain
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire
aux gens pour leur donner envie d'aller
le voir ce qu'on peut juste déplacer les
deux personnes qui sont à rendre public
ce que je sens qu'il me regarde avec
envie et ça me dérange c'est fait
deux personnes là on va on va s'en
occuper vous inquiétez pas docteur
pourrait vous demander quoi la question
vous pouvez dire aux gens pour qu'ils
ont envie d'aller voir votre film
je préfère qu'on parle de biopic banque
qu'on peut donner envie basse et moi et
mon physique parfait sur écran géant
fabien vu le film non parce que en fait
ma famille elle est à l'étranger enfin à
limoges du coup on se voit pas beaucoup
célibataire c'est quoi votre truc
d'hommes deux mois à l'eau là-bas ouais
je suis chez nour a traité un visa mais
s'il est normal l'animateur de l'énergie
ans c'est un peu chiant chiant c'est un
peu long je te voilà pour combien de
temps oh tu te dire je vais je vais
courte et très bien alors ces
célibataires c'est quoi votre clip d'
homme physiquement way et ben en fait
depuis tout à l'heure je regarde
monsieur monsieur quand même gilles
verdez gilles verdez et j'aime bien quoi
c'est vrai moi j'aime bien venir je suis
leur dette
bah ouais je prendrais ci fait je
demande c'est exactement mon style
peut-être juste avec les yeux noirs les
cheveux noirs
ah ouais les abdos et peu de poil
une salle a forcément des copines à ce
moment je préfère qu'on les appelle des
faire valoir
enora si tu veux on va se voir verser
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors et enfin il ya denis brogniart qui
est avec nous ce soir crise à de
nombreuses émanant ça me ferait plaisir
que je participe à koh lanta vous
connaissez koh lanta c'est les gens du
nord qui vont à miami avec les stars
mais que les moustiques d'or salaces et
ça c'est tout ça mais exactement ça vous
dirait le partitionnement nôtre mais pas
du tout
gaby oh gaby toutefois les voir shopping
ça toi donc deux mois est vraiment et
vous savez vous avez un chien dans le
film ouais et ben à votre avis les
chiens d'eau qui le chien du chien de
quelqu'un autour de la table c'est pas
vrai c'est holly oh les gars c'est au
lit c'est au lit dit pavel hapal house
you lie c'est le choc quatre quintaux de
la table ça va dit dires sont exacts
c'est le chantier c'est le chien de la
dèche non c'est le chien des nos races
et sanctionne la mère de ma mère en fait
sur la piste c'est pas vrai la séance
avec ma maman et c'est le chien et ouais
il a été pistonné mais votre maman était
allé assez c'est dingue non sa maman
n'est pas le chien c'est lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]